-Bonjour!
- Salut!
-Je suis la Prof et si vous êtes sur cette
vidéo normalement vous le savez parce qu’on
est sur ma chaîne, et là aujourd’hui je
suis ici pour vous parler de choses qui va
un petit peu plus loin que ce que je fais
d’habitude, et c’est pour ça que je suis
accompagnée de Lou.
-Bonjour… encore.
-Et du coup je te laisse te présenter.
-Ah comme ça, tout de go! Ok. Nan ba moi
du coup c’est Lou a.k.a Lou puisque c’est
mon vrai prénom, voilà, parce qu’il y
a des gens qui pensent que c’est pas mon
vrai prénom mais voilà. Je suis euh… J’ai
une petite chaîne qui s’appelle The life
warp sur laquelle je fais entre autres de
la fiction. Et quelque chose me dit que ça
a un rapport avec ce qu’on va présenter
aujourd’hui.
-Mais tout à faitLou ! Parce que nous sommes
ici pour vous présenter un projet d’une
web série que j’ai écrite il y a quelques
mois déjà, et j’en avait parlé un tout
petit peu sur ma vidéo des 3 ans en disant
«Je la ferai peut-être un jour.» Et
bah là c’est un peu plus concret, on lance
cette web série.
-Ce jour est arrivé.
- Et ce jour est arrivé, et c’est pour
ça que je me fais accompagner de Lou qui
sera ma coréalisatrice sur ce projet et on
est accompagnés de plein d’autres gens
bien aussi.
-Et on va donc vous présenter un peu tout
ça dans cette vidéo.
-Tout à fait. Donc cette série c’est basé,
pour ceux qui suivent Chroniques de Prof sur
les personnages que vous voyez apparaitre
de temps en temps: Aliénor, Lucretia la
romaine et d’autres personnages. Si vous
n’avez jamais vu Chroniques de Prof vous
pourrez tout à fait comprendre par contre.
Mais donc l’idée de départ c’est pourquoi
ces gens qui viennent d’époques différentes
se retrouvent ils au 21e siècle.
-En faisant des vidéos.
-En plus.
-Ça n’a aucun sens.
-J’ai donc repris les personnages de Chroniques
de Prof pour raconter une histoire de science-fiction
dans laquelle on aura des voyages dans le
temps, de l’humour, tout ce qu’on aime
quoi. Et nous allons l’expliquer dans cette
web série qu comprendra 6 épisodes de qualité.
Mais pour ça on a quand même un petit budget.
-On a besoin de thunes.
-Tout à fait.
-Parce qu’il faut pouvoir déjà un minimum
défrayer les gens, acheter/louer du matériel,
payer…
-Les nourrir
-Oui nourrir ces gens.
-Manger, c’est bien.
-J’allais dire payer les repas mais manger.
-La bouffe putain.
-Donc voilà on a fait un budget, au minimum
ça serait bien qu’on arrive à réunir
1500€ qui nous permettrait de faire la base
de tout ce qu’on vient de présenter, mais
après on peut envisager plus puisque que
comme c’est de la science-fiction ben y
aura forcément des ptits effets spéciaux
à ajouter. Et je ne suis pas une spécialiste
d’After effect donc si on peut trouver mieux…
-Moi non plus.
- C’est mieux. Et pour ça vous pouvez retrouver
sur le projet Ulule différents paliers qui
nous permettront de faire des choses de mieux
en mieux selon ce qu’on arrivera à rassembler.
Et pour ça on aura différents personnages
puisque d’habitude j’incarne tout le monde
mais là ça va être un peu compliqué donc
y aura différentes personnes qui joueront
différentes versions de moi et ce sont des
gens très bien qu’on a trouvé.
-Donc on aura pour jouer Lucretia on aura
Clemy de la chaine Clemy Snow que d’ailleurs
si vous connaissez ma chaîne vous l’avez
vue dans beauuuucoup de vidéos.
-Et notamment «Apprends la magie avec Hermione»
-Oui voilà plein de trucs comme ça.
-Et elle fait aussi des choses cool de son
côté.
-Oui plein de trucs. Hum pour jouer Astrid
vous aurez une excellente actrice qui s’appelle
Léa et qui va donner du fil à retordre
-Qui sera bien badass je pense.
-Bien stylée clairement.
-Astrid que vous ne connaissez pas d’ailleurs
mais que vous découvrirez dans la série.
Parce que Astrid elle existe pas.
-Ah ouais?
-Bah on sait pas qui est Astrid je l’avais
jamais nommée.
-Aaah!
-Donc il y a une Astrid que vous avez déjà
vu dans mes vidéos mais vous ne savez pas
qui c’est.
-Suspens!
-Ensuite on aura d’autres personnages mais
on ptet pas dire les noms de tout le monde
- Oui parce que toi du coup tu joueras
-Moi je jouerai la Prof forcément et je
jouerai Aliénor parce que j’aime jouer
Aliénor. Donc j'me la garde celle-là. Et
on aura d’autres personnages bien sur qui
seront joués entre autres par Florence Rivières
qui est une comédienne que j’aime beaucoup,
qui participe à plein de projets biens dont
«Sans vouloir vous déranger» que vous
voyez ici et on aura aussi Guillaume qu’on
retrouve d’habitude sur la chaîne Muséonaute
qui parle d’histoire de l’art et qui participera
au projet.
-Du coup niveau tournage, pour l’instant
on a prévu 3 week ends, 1 en juin et 2 fin
aout, avec une potentielle date de diffusion
je sais plus quand.
-Bah le temps de monter tout ça, ça dépendra
après si y'a plusieurs personnes qui travaillent
sur le montage donc comme on sait pas encore.
-Potentiellement fin 2018 début 2019?
-Oui d’ici fin 2018 j'pense qu’il y a
moyen qu’on commence à diffuser.
-Voilà.
-Tout à fait. On va tourner dans des lieux
divers et variés et ça sera bien.
-Et donc si ça vous intéresse, n’hésitez
pas à lire toutes les informations sur la
page du ulule et à participer financièrement
si vous pouvez, si vous en avez envie.
-Oui, ça nous ferait très plaisir et bien
sur il y aura des contreparties que vous retrouvez
aussi sur le ulule vous aurez tous les détails
et notamment je pense qu’on mettra aussi
en place une newsletter pour les personnes
qui ont contribué pour que vous voyez où
en est le projet et comment on avance ou pas
mais on avancera.
-Oui clairement, lentement mais surement.
Et du coup voilà on vous dit à très vite.
A très bientôt, en tout cas sur ma chaîne
vous me retrouverez ben y'a 2 vidéos qui
sortent en avril en plus de celle-ci donc
vous allez avoir plein de nouvelles choses
historiques et dans tous les cas même si
le projet de web série se met en place, je
continue à faire Chroniques de Prof à côté.
Voilà merci.
-Salut!
-Au revoir
-Au revoir.
Générique
-Et nous allons l’expliquer dans cette petite
série qui comprendra 8 ép euh non
- C’est 6, c’est bien la meuf sait de
quoi elle parle.
-C’est quoi le projet?
-Pourquoi jsuis là? Pourquoi on me filme?
-Qui êtes-vous?
-Et du coup au niveau des dates de tournage,
pour l’instant on a prévu 2 week end, yen
aura un en juin normalement… 3 week ends?
-Oui
-Jsuis pas au courant.
-Yen a deux fin aout.
-Yen a deux fin aout?
-Oui.
-Ah bon. Ah putain mais oui! La meuf est
au courant! La meuf sait de quoi elle parle!
-Réalisatrice.